okay, so now let's go back to
Moments, we're talking about moments on the one.
And we said that we will revisit.
the idea of the moment
the moment generating function
You know here on day two.
So let's go back over to the reader.
And let's bring up the example.
from the
Moment.
when you hear of words like standard deviation
mean
kurtosis and skewness
these are kinds of
Moments, these are moments.
and moments describe
certain characteristics about the probability distribution
if I take you
If I take you back to the slide from day one.
So here we have this slide from day one.
And these are what the moments are. There
are four kinds of moments. You have
the mean.
Also known as the expected value for a random
variable.
Then you have the standard deviation.
Which you arrive at using the variance?
You have the skewness.
And then of course the fourth moment is the ketosis.
so the way you work your way towards
the second moment as you calculate
the first moment the week get to the third movement is a calculate
the second moment fourth moment. You need the third
moment. So each moment would need a proceeding moment.
for its measurement
so
Let's now look at.
the
moment generating function
for all four moments
Let's go to the reader to.
Make a note of this.
So moment.
generating
function
Okay, the moment generating function.
is a type of
generating function
What does that mean?
a generating function in general in
mathematics is a way of
capturing the idea
of an ink of an infinite sequence
of numbers
if you go back to the reader.
This may become clearer.
calculating the population mean
Has the same formula as calculating the expected
value?
and that formula that sequence
is
what the moment generating function?
Talks about it is what the moment generally function.
expresses
that
this function is go is
This function is this sequence the
sequence of numbers?
and that sequence
Is further expressed by this expression?